3 The
heat flashed Oh, I
'm sorry, Tsubaki hasn't gotten used to the opportunity yet.
What are you saying?
It's a graph, but the results of
my research I think Tsubaki-san's
powers are just like those of an entertainer
.
Departure
Hitachi needs to work a little harder It's
not just you guys It
's amazing whether we can match Mr. Kiba in the
5th edition I can't lose either
It's normal.
This is the 5
-minute throat monthly report card for the 15th edition
.  It's
a pity that it wasn't there, but the data is true.
Yeah,
and it seems that Tsubaki-san hasn't changed our grades in the 5th edition even once since he joined
.
The individual was excellent. If the
edition didn't go well, there's no meaning
.